okay so the music's turned down so I
think that's time to go somebody in the
back want to give me a thumbs up all
right we got a thumbs up we're ready to
go hi
so I'm Ryan Noack I'm a developer and
architect working on asp net core I have
a long time at guess at this point is P
net team member I've been a part of the
team since before Donna core was a thing
back when it was a SP net five and then
when it was project K hopefully some of
you all have been with us through all of
that growing pains and all of those
times if you want you can find me on
Twitter and sometime later today you'll
be able to find all of my presentation
materials at that address so today we're
going to be talking about some new ideas
as part of asp net core and we're gonna
be talking about some things that are a
little bit further in the future these
are some big ideas that are gonna shape
the next five years of asp net core
development now something that probably
sticks out is that all of these are
going to be tied to something that
exists you'll probably realize that when
i'm talking about this and we realize at
this point that asp net core is pretty
broad we're at 300 after all but there's
still plenty of refinement to do and i
want to share some of these ideas to get
your feedback and get you thinking about
things and try to convince you that
there's still some innovation left in
the tank for some of the things that
you're already familiar with so you
probably didn't realize today when you
came in here that you're gonna make a
deal with me
but look the deal is I'm gonna share
some information about some of our bold
ideas and some of our future thinking
things and in exchange I just want you
to remember that none of these things
are committed roadmap nothing that
you're gonna hear today is an
announcement these are all just ideas
and things that we're gonna develop
further and hopefully get your feedback
on some of these things that we're gonna
talk about might be the right solution
to the wrong problem or they might be
the wrong solution to the right problem
or they just might be things that we
decide not to do for whatever reason so
keep that in mind as you're hearing
about this stuff as with any of these
talks that are coming from Microsoft
tell us what you like tell us what you
would use it for your feedback is
incredibly valuable and helping us
understand what to build and what to do
so first up we're going to talk about
something called project bedrock and in
order to understand what that is we're
going to need a little bit of background
about the HTTP server so I want to
introduce you to Kestrel Kestrel is our
HTTP server and it was
written it was written by engineers on
our team as part of dotnet core 1.0
because well we needed a cross-platform
HTTP server if you're gonna build a web
platform that works everywhere you need
a server that works everywhere so we had
a long legacy with is on Windows but we
wanted to build a server that we could
take everywhere and give everybody the
same experience no matter what operating
system you're developing on or what
operating system you're deploying to now
what you're seeing on this screen is the
results from the tech empower web
framework benchmarks this in particular
is the plain text benchmark which is
part of the tech empower suite there are
some more and this particular one is
like a 50 meter sprint so you should
think about this like what's the minimum
amount of framework overhead like what's
the fastest your server can do it's a
measurement of how much overhead the
server adds and what are the sort of raw
capabilities of the server there are
some other benchmarks that are part of
tech and power that a little bit more
realistic but this one is really just
hello world and it's kind of a race
right so you can see us hanging out here
at about 10:00 or 11:00 10:00 and 11:00
or both us the red lines but really this
is a 17 way tie
so with these tech and power benchmarks
for plain text there's currently a 717
way tie at the maximum theoretical
throughput for this particular benchmark
we're maxing out the network if you look
at what some of these other frameworks
are over here in this language column I
guess it's abbreviated LNG you see rust
C++ go and the only other sort of
managed stack that you'll see there is
Java the rest of these are all going to
be native code kinds of stacks so
clearly we're doing something right if
in this competitive benchmark we're
getting into the top sort of echelon and
we're with everybody else in a tie to
max out what's possible at the benchmark
so that's that's something we've done so
far this is kind of a layering diagram
of what Castro looks like in asp net
core 200 and you might not have much
experience thinking about these bottom
two layers because they're not the kinds
of things you typically write
applications with you're not normally
thinking about what's going on inside
the details of the web server when you
write an application but that's okay
because that's what I'm here to explain
to you so before an HTTP request gets to
the middleware pipeline the server has
already done a bunch of complicated
thing
the server manages TCP connections it
deals with timeouts it deals with a
bunch of security features and it
translates raw bytes going over the
Internet into the kinds of objects that
you get to interact with in your asp net
core application so if we gave you
instead a server where you just get like
a stream and raw bytes and you have to
parse the headers yourself and you have
to write the body yourself and you have
to write the headers yourself that
wouldn't be very good you wouldn't want
to use it it wouldn't be very productive
for for you at the bottom of this
diagram on the left side and that's from
v1 is libuv libuv
if you're not familiar with it is the C
library that's at the core of nodejs
people probably use node at least
hopefully everybody's heard of node so
we actually in v1 took the the library
that's at the heart of node and made it
the cornerstone of our server the reason
why we would do that is well they wrote
a pretty good implementation and it's
cross-platform so we had an existing
cross-platform library that we could use
for sockets and TCP and all kinds of
networking related things that we could
build a server on top of and Lybia V's
purpose in all of this is that it does
those things that I just mentioned it
handles TCP connections and it deals
with translating raw bytes and sending
those in and out from the wire then a
funny thing happened as we worked on
kestrel and we went on the sort of
performance journey of asp net core we
have grulla movies performance so we got
to a point where libuv was the
bottleneck of our stack and we had an
opportunity to take a big bet on net and
make dotnet better so along with that we
replace libuv with dotnet sockets and we
did a bunch of work on dotnet sockets to
make their performance great and that
gets that gets us to where we are right
now so if you think about kestrel and
serving your application what's actually
going on at the network layer is it's
using that familiar class system that
socket socket like we're using types in
the bcl-2 do all of our network io in
kestrel and that's because of
investments that we made in performance
at that layer so we think of this bottom
layer here we call this the transport
layer since that's the thing that's
transporting bytes somewhere else when
you make a network connection now then
we started work on HTTP to HTTPS a
change at the top layer of the server
so if you think about what happens when
you have a different network protocol
there's a different structure different
parsing different interactions with
streams those kind of things and so we
extracted that top layer and turned it
into something we call the protocol
layer and we have three protocols that
we support that are in the Box we have
HTTP HTTP two and signal are and we had
to extract a genuine layer there because
we needed to replace HTTP with something
else so now we've got this sort of
delicious layer cake here on the bottom
layer we have the transport layer we
have connections in raw IO on the top
layer we have protocols the things that
provide structure and provide meaning to
those raw bytes and provide useful
semantics that you use to build
applications and in the middle we have
that delicious layer of peanut butter
that we call the server and you can sort
of think of that like the traffic cop
that's mediating between those two
things and managing the contracts
between those two layers so transports
and protocols what do we get when
transports and protocols are replaceable
well we have a bunch of options so you
could have a transport that is named
pipes you could do HTTP over named pipes
you could do HTTP over a UNIX domain
socket you could do HTTP 3 you could do
signal or you could do AMQP and MQTT
which are some new protocols that are
emerging that are really exciting so we
kind of developed this recipe for how we
want to architect the server and
developed a recipe for how we make those
components replaceable so that we're
better equipped to deal with change in
the future and to adopt new stuff in the
future so that's basically product
project in bedrock to find bedrock is an
API that we created for client server
networking we're not going to go over it
in detail here because it's a little bit
kind of expert and and maybe not
something that you're going to use
inside your actual application but
bedrock is the API and the design sort
of exercise that led to the creation of
all those types in system i/o pipelines
so if you've heard us talk about high
performance and networking is he sharp
if you've read about span and read only
real nice trucks and all those kinds of
things a lot of that work across dotnet
aligned with this bedrock effort and a
lot of those types like pipelines and
spans were sort of shaped by this effort
to say let's get our network stack in in
order
let's get the server part of this into a
design where we're ready to replace
these components with different
components as we need to adapt to change
so these api's are in.net core if you
own something that does its own network
communication they're there for you to
start using you start building with and
the other sort of thing about this is
well we think that dotnet is actually a
really good language for doing this sort
of low-level Network communication with
all the changes that have gone into
c-sharp lately in c-sharp 7 2 & 7 3 and
with pipes and spans and all these other
great low-level primitives we feel like
we're actually in a really good place
for you to write low-level code that
does Network i/o and it's safe like
you're not going to have memory problems
you're not gonna have crashes and it
doesn't have to be quite as complicated
as doing this in like C or C++ if you
remember back to that diagram that we
looked at earlier there's a whole lot of
servers at the top that are written in
native code and some of them are in safe
native languages like rust and go and
some of them are in well less safe
native languages like C and C++ Java is
up there too in a few cases we think the
dotnet is getting better for this kind
of thing every day and is a really good
choice for building this kind of
detailed low-level code that you can do
safely if you're if you're careful so
now I want to show you a quick demo and
who's hopefully people here have heard
of single R if you haven't heard of
signal R there's one hand up there all
right we got one guy so if you haven't
used signal R before signal R is a
real-time two-way communication protocol
primarily it's used in browsers with
WebSockets what does that all mean well
primarily that means that you can use it
to build a chat application so I'm gonna
show you I'm gonna show you my great
chat application because that's what
everybody does the first time with
signal R and then we'll get a little bit
weird with it okay so I'm gonna go ahead
and fire this up and I've got my chat
window here and for any good chat demo
you need two windows so I'll split that
off
okay and I'll say hello from the left
side and when I do that it's gonna
appear on both screens because I'm using
signal are here so both of these both of
these windows are using the JavaScript
JavaScript or typescript signal our
client connecting to my asp net course
server running signal are and they're
sending and receiving messages from the
same hub they're part of the same
chatroom I I can come over here and I
can say hello from the right side and
these are just broadcasts everybody
who's listening to this hub is getting
all the same kinds of messages if you
wanted to see how this works I could
bring up the developer tools over here
and I can go to WebSocket I have to
refresh for Chrome to pick this up and
you can see that there's a WebSocket
here that's what this that's what this
little thing indicates if I send another
message here then you can see I'm
getting a WebSocket response from the
server that's this doubt this red down
arrow means sending down to me and
that's how I'm getting this message it's
coming over that real time connection so
let's get a little bit weird with it I
have got this other client here and this
is this is a console client and what I'm
using in here is I'm using the vanilla
dotnet c-sharp signal our client but
what I have done is I've replaced the
transport layer and it's not doing
WebSockets it's actually doing TCP
directly so there's no HTTP here there's
no doing an HTTP request and then doing
a negotiation and then opening a
WebSocket it's at a much much lower
level than that so I can send you know
hello from TCP and it's gonna show up in
both of these windows over here just
like it we're coming from a WebSocket is
that cool it's a little bit cool okay
great
so so that's that's kind of interesting
why why might you care about that why
might you want more options than just
using WebSockets what kind of things do
you get out of replacing the network
protocol well different transport layer
protocols might be more efficient they
might be more direct they might use less
resources or they might give you
different security options like using a
UNIX domain socket or using a named pipe
gives you a different set of security
options than using a WebSocket maybe
you're building an application that has
to do communication and you don't want
to think about
how do I'd secure HTTP as part of this
application you could do some kind of
Windows thing with named pipes so
there's a bunch of different options
that you have here and the the bedrock
effort is really just about giving you
options for the network protocol and
about setting us up with more ability to
customize and build and grow this area
in the future so the changes that are
different here the things that make this
work from your normal sort of signal our
application I have a listener here so
I'm listening on the loopback at port
5,000 and I'm not passing anything in
here so this is just gonna do the normal
Kestrel thing it's gonna normally run my
HTTP pipeline so when my browser
WebSocket client connects it's gonna go
down this pipeline it's gonna do the
normal browser WebSocket thing but then
I've got this other listener here and
I'm listening on loopback 5006 and
instead of going down the normal HTTP
pipeline I've got this builder here and
I can show you it's a listen options
builder it's not an application builder
it's not a sauna asp net core middleware
pipeline it's something much more
primitive and low-level than that and
signal already has the support in the
box to wire itself up to that so I can
wire up this same chat hub that I'm
using over HTTP and WebSockets directly
to that TCP connection over here and my
client-side application the only thing
that's different in this console
application is instead of giving myself
a WebSocket URL I'm giving myself a TCP
connection and saying hey go to this TCP
address so the future of project bedrock
what is that what does that feature hold
we think that these api's are pretty
good and so they're public and stable
and 3.0 what's left here is that we need
more protocols and transports so on the
horizon is quick quick as part of HTTP 3
it's a new transport layer protocol that
is used instead of TCP with with HTTP 3
the team is already working on and
thinking about HTTP 3 we were a little
bit behind where we wanted to be with
HTTP 2 what we got there
were sort of committed to being a little
bit more ahead of the game with HTTP 3
and that sort of things are already
happening the other aspect of this is
you there's a long tail of libraries
that do network
do database connections to Redis talk to
message queues we think the community
has a potential to benefit from this
work immensely we have created a sort of
battle-hardened recipe around doing this
kind of efficient networking
communication and we think that the
libraries that are out there in the
dotnet community can leverage this and
continue to get better and better so
thanks to David Fowler who helped me
prepare this section if you want to see
these examples or see these api's or
some of followers demos you can follow
these links later and check those things
out next i want to talk about project
Houdini which relates to all of our
frameworks we ship and how they
integrate or don't integrate with the
rest of our framework so let me ask does
this seem balanced I have got a list
here of features that exist in asp net
core and i'm sort of dividing them up
between whether they're implemented at
the platform layer or whether they're
part of asp net core MVC so we have the
asp net core platform on the left with
like a couple things that are unique to
it and we have MVC on the right with
this like embarrassment of riches right
like there's all these features over in
this right column that are unique to MVC
let's add some more frameworks to this
mess so let's add signal R and let's add
GRP see anything that's part of the
platform layer you get a uniform
experience across all these frameworks
it's shared it's reusable it's sort of
set up for you to get the same thing no
matter what of these experiences you're
using anything in MVC if you want to
share it across any of these frameworks
you don't really have the option to do
that because it's locked to MVC so our
options if we want to say reuse routing
inside of signal are well we ended up
duplicating that and that's actually
what that's actually what signal our
prior to 3.0 was like is it had its own
routing system that was separate from
the routing system in MVC so lately I've
been peeling the onion here to see how
many platform level features should be
abstracted from MVC how many things that
are here should probably be pushed down
lower in the stack and should be made
more general purpose and more reusable
routing was the obvious place to start
here because so many other decisions are
driven by what routing does so in 3.0 we
made a change to the routing system and
we made a new routing system be the
default
the old one is still there you can still
use it but we're strongly encouraging
everybody to get to this new one and the
reason is because well it's it's
Universal it solves a bunch of problems
with the old one we think it's better in
every way
and we're working we're working to
address scenarios that keep people from
adopting the new thing get them on it
new stuff like blazer server and gr PC
don't integrate with the old system they
only integrate with the new one
gradually over time we're gonna move
more and more scenarios onto the new
system and eventually try to rip the old
one out and as you can see in this code
sample there's a whole galaxy of stuff
that's plugging in here to the same
routing system we got controllers we've
got pages we got signal R we got JRP see
we got blazer you can do router where
you can do all kinds of powerful things
with this new routing system the other
thing that's cool about this is they're
using the same off system so not only
and that's that's part of the payoff of
this is the routing system solves a
bunch of problems between integration
between frameworks like MVC and
middleware like authorization so all of
these frameworks that can use this
routing system all use the same off
system it's all integrated and it all
works the same now in the interest of
time I'm not gonna do a super deep dive
on the design of the routing system I
did do a talk about that an NBC London
that's called lessons learned building
MVC about half of that talk is dedicated
to this area so if you're interested in
that you should be able to find that on
YouTube and check it out and get a
better understanding of this so this is
a layering diagram of what things look
like now that we have endpoint routing
in the picture you can see on top we've
got or on the bottom you've got server
which we talked about already
you've got middle where you've got
routing which is a particular middleware
and then on top you've got all these
lovely frameworks that are built on top
of routing so I'm really happy with this
because if I can make a diagram that's
this simple and it describes the truth
then that's a really good position to be
in because it means that things are sort
of in the right shape and everything is
right with the world
so now we're set up to unpack project
Houdini what endpoint routing did is we
took some MVC features and we made them
disappear
they didn't disappear exactly they got
turned into more useful things and got
put into some other situations they I
like to think they sort of got broken
off and got shared lower in the
framework in practice this is a little
less graceful than it sounds
we haven't been able to invent magic yet
but gradually over time we're going to
be migrating people to the new system
we're gonna make sure that people are
happy with it and that it does what they
want and eventually the old one will go
away that's a long process and we expect
that it's going to take multiple
releases for any of this kind of work
because we genuinely want to make it
worth your while if we're asking you to
change something we think there's a lot
of value in this for everyone and it
often gives us an opportunity if we're
refactoring something or real layering
something to address a bunch of
scenarios that we found out about since
the last time we worked on this code and
before anybody gets upset about this
we're not trying to make MVC disappear
your controllers and your pages and all
those things are going to be around
forever and they're gonna be primary to
the programming model of asp net core
forever we still think that controllers
are one of the best ideas for doing web
in dotnet and we don't plan to like take
them away what we're talking about here
is just about giving people more options
so I want to architect your brain for a
minute and I want to talk about what
controllers do and what some other
things kind of do controllers are a very
like declarative solution right they
give you a place to put methods on a
class they give you a place to write
parameters they give you a place to
declare a return type they give you a
place to put attributes and they give
you a lot of power as long as the power
that you want fits with that model so if
you hear me right like what you can
express with your parameters and your
return types and your attributes if it's
a good fit for how the framework behaves
is what you want then it feels really
good to use if what you want is not a
good fit for what the framework provides
with those attributes and parameters and
return types then it doesn't feel very
good to use on the other hand imperative
solutions you write the code you want
and it does the things that you want
they're often a little bit more verbose
but in exchange for that everything is
very pay-for-play like you you told us
exactly what to do and we're just doing
it they're usually a little bit simpler
to understand because there's no magic
and there's no secrets going on and if
you're very performance sensitive in
some scenario imperative solutions are
often a better choice because you're in
control you control everything that
it's there so it becomes apparent if you
if what I said about fit and declarative
solutions kind of got yeah like right
here we're missing imperative solutions
for a bunch of the things that NBC
provides so like model binding for
matters validation a bunch of those
things we don't really have options like
we don't really have code for you to
call to do those things or if you've
tried to do it you've realized you'd
have to write like 20 lines of code and
you gave up you said this is complicated
I can't maintain this I don't understand
this that's that's our fault that's on
us I think I think we're missing I think
we're missing some stuff here I think
we're missing some solutions that make
those kinds of things possible so we
sort of asked myself like well a good
way to solve that problem is to think
about what would it take for you to be
happy and successful writing is B net
core apps with no framework at all like
what if there was no MVC what if you
what if you just wrote the code right
this kind of style is really popular
with go and with no js' and with a bunch
of other styles of frameworks and text
ax there's some frameworks and dotnet
that do this and some pieces of
infrastructure that do it hasn't really
caught on in dotnet at the same rate as
it has in other places but I wanted to
give it a try and I wanted to think
about what this would look like so I
made a graph this isn't scientific I get
to make up the criteria and the results
so very very arbitrary but hopefully it
helps demonstrate my point to you if
you're a little bit of a visual person
so this is a graph of how declarative
and approach is versus how rich it feels
and I want to I want you to think about
richness as how easily can you find a
solution to your problem that feels
right so if we're talking about MVC and
you're thinking about okay I want to
read some JSON from the body there's
from body attribute right that feels
right you're telling us what you want
and we're doing it or if you're using
API controller you don't even have to
say from body we just do it we assume
that's what you want and it feels right
richness is ultimately what you want in
a framework it's what makes you happy
when you use something like MVC your
razor pages being declarative is
probably the most common way to get
there and
however if you're optimizing for
performance you might not want to be
declarative because every feature has a
cost and you might not always want the
cost of all those features so for
controllers we're sort of over here in
this like eighty percent bucket right
very very declarative because you
express everything by methods and
attributes and there's only a few
concerns that you're expected to handle
yourself inside your action method the
framework does the rest the key is that
it feels really good if you have the
right tools to solve your problems which
is why I'm only giving us like an 80%
and richness there's some tools here
that are missing if you contrast that
with routing well you get to write
delegates it's like writing a middleware
like it's very bare-bones you don't
really have a lot of tools available to
you and so it's not very rich either if
you want solutions to the kinds of
problems you have or the kind of tasks
you have to perform you have to write
those pieces of code yourself so I've
been doing a lot of thinking about what
it would look like to make solutions to
those problems I don't want to add more
declarative stuff because that would
just sort of turn routing into MVC and
we already have MVC controllers already
do that so what if we added more
imperative constructs what if we added
more services I could interact with and
more ways of solving the same problems
that would work with something like
routing on its own and I reckon it would
still be useful for the times where
you're using controllers as well
so that brings me to project Houdini and
something I like to call route to code
and I'm really asking two questions here
how can i how can we make minimal
back-end services feel good I want to
hover in on that word minimal when I say
minimal I mean like do you have a
service that's gonna have like four
endpoints in it do you have a do you
have a do you have a service where
you're gonna write like 50 lines of code
do you feel like asp net core can do
that we look at some other tech stacks
out there and we say well go can do that
I bet we could make dotnet do that in
addition I want to think about if you're
writing one of these small applications
that's going to be really simple can we
remove some concepts can we simplify the
number of things you think about can we
make it scale really well to having a
really small amount of code I think we
already do a pretty good job when you
have a large amount of code I think
we've found this niche with people
having 50 controllers or 100
or 50 projects or hundred projects in
their solution does it feel really good
to use a small amount of code with asp
net core and that's really what I'm
after here so I have a demo of this and
I've taken some risks and I've made some
I've made some assumptions and I've
shaken things up a little bit and I'm
gonna point out some of those things to
you to you so what if you created a new
way of speed at core application and
like this was what you get by default
and just to prove that I'm not bluffing
I'll open up you can ignore the man
behind the curtain and ignore these
other projects here I've got my weather
application and I've got a config file
and beyond that I've literally got just
one file here there's one code file I am
cheating a little bit I will acknowledge
that I'm cheating I put my my data model
in another project but let's assume that
you you've got some data model and we're
really talking about could the asp net
core part of your app be one class one
file that simple so what I've done here
is I've kind of combined like program CS
and startup this is this is all of those
things in once and I've introduced a
base class and I've given it a
presumptive namespace to assume like
it's part of the framework already like
I'm already shipping this great and look
at how much complexity goes away like I
don't I don't need a configure services
because I haven't added any services I
don't need that big program main method
because I'm not customizing what goes on
there anyway I mean who is and I just
have this configure method with the
middleware pipeline that I care about so
it's really kind of slimmed down in
bare-bones and simple let's try and add
some code to this so I'm going to build
a really simple weather processing
application and we're just going to do
some weather forecasting and I've
already written this class which is my
weather supercomputer so I'll get an
instance of my computer and I'm just
going to close over this my weather
supercomputer I'm just going to close
over this and use this here and it's
going to be treated kind of as like it's
a singleton if I wanted to make this
come from di I could register it as a
service and I could just say I could
just say services dot get required
service and get it that way but we're
not going to mess with that right now so
now I'd like to add some routes or I'd
like to add some things that are gonna
handle requests here and I can do that
with this endpoints builder so I would
just say and
dot map get I'm gonna have to sort of
actions here I'm gonna handle weather
for a place and then inside here I'm
gonna get the HTTP context and I'm gonna
read this place route value because
that's how I'm gonna look up what the
weather forecast is for our place equal
to I have to cast it to a string route
values is untyped context request route
values and I want to get the place and
then I'm going to take this place and
I'm gonna ask my whether a supercomputer
can it tell me about the weather Peter
get forecast and I'll give it the place
and then what do I want to do well I
want to write this out as JSON one of
the one of the things that you run into
a lot with dotnet is that the efficient
ways of doing things are often not the
simplest ways of doing things so if I
want it to be really simple
I could serialize this to a string and
then I could write the string if I want
it to be really efficient I could add a
using I could create a sterilizer I
could call some complicated method blah
so we can we can help we're here to help
one of the things that's in one of the
ideas that's in my prototype here is
well what if I had methods on the
response for that and you see that and
you're like how did we get this far how
did we get to v3 without having this
it's kind of its kind of mystifying
right let's do the same thing let's
handle some input and I'm just going to
copy paste this and I'll customize it so
we're gonna handle a post we're going to
use the same route we're going to get
the place the same and instead of
getting the weather from our computer
this is an update of a weather forecast
that's coming from one of my many
reporters in the field I'm going to read
that from the body read
Aysen async I have to pass him a type I
want and ill deserialize and then
instead of instead of writing it back
out to the response I'm just gonna
update my computer update forecast place
weather so like do you have apps that
are this simple
do you have scenarios where you need to
write like two things or three things
can we make it better can we make it
feel nice to use and and everything now
there there are some things to talk
about here there are some things that
you're giving up so you're giving up
unit testability right because these are
these are methods that are lambdas that
are in routing right
you can write integration tests for this
but you can't really write unit tests
for it one of the things that makes
controllers the way they are it's on
purpose right the fact that controllers
are classes with methods that you can
call it on purpose it's for unit testing
what we're missing here and this is I
think sort of an artifact of the
prototype is well we're missing rich
model binding and validation I'm sort of
cheating a little bit by saying yeah I'm
going to read the Jason I'm gonna write
the Jason I'm assuming that they sent me
Jason if they didn't send me Jason it's
gonna crash pretty hard so a real
version of this would include those
options but it would also probably
include low these sort of low-level
primitives like reading and writing
Jason directly for the case where you're
not willing to pay the cost for that so
there's a future where we're giving you
more options here and I think it looks
like something like this plus let's take
model binding out of MVC and make it
separate let's take four matters out of
mu C and make them separate and give you
some options to build these kind of
applications cool so that's that demo
so the future of this looks like us
continued I think looks like us
continuing the work we started with
routing we want to gradually and gently
evolve MVC in a way that you're happy to
come with us
and you think that it's helping you and
we want to move features down in the
platform this helps make MVC enas Pinet
core and signal R and G RPC and all
these other things feel more consistent
and capable no matter what feature set
you're using in parallel with this we
want to continue to try and build up
this sort of small code small concept
small complexity scenario and we want to
add more options that give you direct
control when you feel like you need it
let's shift gears pretty dramatically
now and I want to talk to you about
publishing I know it's a really exciting
topic who here's show of hands who here
has got an application that they do a
self-contained publish with that is not
that many people Wow okay I'm gonna
assume that the rest of you just were
too shy to put your hand up so I have
got some screenshots on this slide
comparing a normal self-contained
publish with a single file
self-contained publish single file
self-contained publish is a thing that
we added in is in Dona core 3 oh and it
gives you the ability to sort of bundle
all the executable parts of your publish
output into a single file so if you
remember we started talking about
Donette core one oh it was really really
exciting idea that we could have a
version of.net core that you could just
you know drag and drop somewhere now
we're talking about having a version of
your application that includes dotnet
core that is just a single file that you
can drag and drop somewhere right so
looking at this data in a little bit
more detail
single file today you get five files
most of them are config and you get one
runnable file and for a normal publish
you get a whopping 324 files they're
both around the same size they're both
coming in just under 95 megabytes and
the reason why it's 95 megabytes is
includes all of net it includes all of
the dependencies that you need to run
net including native code including xml
including crypto everything that's not
part of the operating system for
whatever platform you're running on is
is part of that publish output these
results by the way are for release on
linux but it's not significantly
different on other operating systems so
we asked ourselves like well 95 Meg's is
kind of a lot can we make this better
can we lean into this can we do a little
bit more so we've done some
investigations into this and we we
really looked at a bunch of different
axes that sort of push the boundaries of
the dotnet tech so even if you're not a
self-contained published person I hope
you're gonna hear about some stuff in
this section that's gonna energize you
and excite you because there's some
other things that are happening here
that are that are gonna be useful to you
no matter what kind of dotnet you're
doing so our criteria for sort of
looking into this is we don't want to
make any compromises on performance we
feel like our performance for a espenak
core is really strong already for
runtime throughput we don't want to give
up any of that we do want to make
startup performance better we feel like
that's not good enough and so a big part
of this investigation was well what if
we try to improve startup performance
what if we threw everything at it what
could we do in addition to that we're
willing to pay some additional costs for
publish time if it takes another ten or
fifteen seconds when you publish that's
not typically an operation that you're
waiting for we think that 10 to 15
seconds of additional time if it's a
published versus a build is acceptable
that's a trade-off you'd be willing to
get to to live with if you're getting a
lot out of it
and lastly any sort of tools or workflow
changes or fundamental pivots we make
to.net have to be something that
everybody can leverage so all of these
changes have to be things that are
within striking distance of every person
in every app if you have to jump through
like a million flaming hoops to get to
the point of being able to do do a
self-contained publish or do a small
publish or leverage any of these new
features not a solution if we can't take
you with us it's not worth doing you
might be asking at this point why do why
don't we just use mono we know that mono
can make some really small apps I will
also work on blazer blazer is a mono app
right now and it's it's about you know
under five Meg's or so we know that mono
is optimized for that and kind of has
that that going on already and the
answer is because this is about server
we wanted it to be based on core CLR and
we didn't want to lose any of the nice
performance we have or things that we
have with core CLR we are using a lot of
the ideas from mono and we were using a
lot of the toolchain
so we're not ignoring that that exists
and we're not throwing it away but we're
using core CLR as our starting point
this led to a bunch of ideas all over
net to try and make this better and I'm
going to talk through over the next
couple of minutes what some of these
things are and then I'll show you some
data so the runtime team was able to
write a more advanced version of the
single file host I know I've shared with
you already in three oh you can do a
publish and you can get a single file
host out of it that's got all the
runtime all the native stuff in one one
package they've made a really advanced
version of that as part of this
prototype that has all your assemblies
and all your native components in it but
it's designed in such a way that when it
loads those assemblies it just puts them
in a memory Maps them into a location
that the loader can understand and is
able to load those assemblies with zero
copies so there's no like unzipping
files to disk or copying things around
in memory it's really really advanced
and it's probably about as optimized as
something like this could get if we
still wanted to retain assembly identity
we have done experiments in the past
where we say let's just put all your
assemblies in one big blob it doesn't go
well it breaks library code it breaks
assumptions that library authors have it
creates some big problems so this is
about as efficient as it can get for
doing something like this the change is
relatively neutral on size and it
decreases the startup time significantly
because there's no extra copying
happening so this gives us a single file
what kinds of things can we do to make
it faster you can open the context menu
so to make things faster and I'm talking
about startup performance so how do we
get into your app we have a couple tools
one that we already have is called
cross-gen if you haven't heard of
cross-gen before that's okay you're
already betting benefiting from it
because it's already on for you in most
scenarios where you're running your code
cross-gen is something we use on and
pretty much everything we ship that
ships in the box with dotnet core and
what it does is it does a lot of the
work that the JIT can do up front there
are some limitations on things that
cross-gen can't do and there are some
things that cross-gen does slightly less
well that we avoid but generally you
should think of cross-gen does the JIT
and the loaders work upfront as much as
possible to try and make the initial run
of your managed code faster and what it
does is it trades speed for size
so you're getting a whole lot of startup
speed you're giving up a lot of size
because things are getting bigger
because in addition to the IL version of
your code you've got native versions of
your code in the same DLL however since
we wanted to preserve startup we didn't
want to I guess go backwards or regress
in our startup performance cross-gen was
a must because we have that on today
which hurts the size goal a little bit
if you had a scenario where you really
cared about the size and you didn't care
at all about the startup performance
turning this off as an option you have
you can strip this out and you'll get a
little bit smaller by a couple megabytes
so a single file host here does a big
does a big part of the heavy lifting to
try and make the performance better in
this scenario and it's a it's basically
an improvement over every other option
that we have for this in this case today
at the managed layer we're peeling the
onion here
we basically used a hello world kind of
asp net rest api application and we're
trying to figure out what contributes to
startup and the way that we approach
that is like well let's profile and then
let's slice off the features that show
up as being the most expensive and then
let's profile and measure and let's
continue that exercise until we get to a
set of recommendations about things that
don't feel good or things that could be
removed the outcome of doing all this
investigation is is actually genuinely
surprised me there's not a lot going on
in the managed code that's slow from our
point of view what is slow is just the
volume of code that has to run its
startup when you consider something like
NBC there's just a lot of stuff
happening and the best path forward for
us we feel like rather than optimizing
individual bits of code which has its
place as well is well let's just try to
let's just try to run less of it so
depending on the scenario are there
features that you're paying for that you
don't need could we remove them things
that come up here are like file Watchers
for JSON config file watchers are
expensive
reading JSON config is relatively
expensive compared to the other things
that are going on and start up setting
up logging the first time the way it's
done is relatively expensive compared to
the other things that start up comparing
the code sample we just saw with the
kind of applications people build today
MVC is very expensive compared to that
code sample so we're taking a hard look
at what features feel like they need to
be
part of this path some of those features
need to go on a diet and some of those
features need to be removed completely
but we think that the path forward here
if we want to make startup time better
for Aspen our core applications is
really about trying to get more features
off the critical path next to improve
size we turned on the linker so
hopefully some people have played with
the linker and I know you have because I
know I've talked to you some of you and
I know some of you in the audience we're
at my Blaser workshop with Steve the
last couple days so Blazer uses the
linker mano uses the linker for xamarin
and we ship support for the linker in
Donna core three oh so if you want to
turn on a very very conservative form of
trimming as part of your publish in 3.0
you have that option the the form of
trimming that we ship in the box with
the linker is basically it will look at
the assemblies that are coming out of
your publish output and say if this
assembly is not used at all let's just
skip it which seems like a very safe and
conservative thing to do there are more
aggressive and more radical things that
you can do so it says here can remove
unused dotnet code and assemblies let's
talk about why unused using quotes so if
you've ever heard the term tree shaking
before I want to try and provide a
definition for it
what does tree shaking really mean the
rude the rude quick definition I would
give you tree shaking means that you
start at Maine and you do static
analysis to try to find every piece of
donek code every method every type and
every member that's used every type
that's constructed every member that's
used you start at Maine and you go out
where you go out from there using static
analysis until you run out of things to
look at by the end you have a list of
things that you know are used everything
else that you haven't seen is gone it
just gets wiped that's the like most
aggressive form of trimming that we can
do and that's generally what people mean
when they sort of talk about tree
shaking so in this example the question
to ask is not what's going to be removed
the question to ask is actually what's
going to be kept right because that's
how the algorithm works so Maine a B and
D need to be kept because we've seen use
to them everything else which is C and D
can be
removed so there are some challenges
with this naturally running the linker
on a large busy dotnet code codebase is
really hard and has a lot of sort of
innate difficulties that we need to work
through it turns out Donette libraries
and frameworks are very complex and not
not in the not in the way that
necessarily everybody's really smart but
like in a bad way when you think about
the linker myself included we do a lot
of things that outsmart the linker and
outsmart static analysis and if we want
this to work if we want to have this
capability for dotnet we need to solve
those kinds of things so what happens if
you only call a method through
reflection
well the linker tries to make some
assumptions about things it tries to
figure out what you're doing but like
really the right answer is if you're
only calling a method through reflection
too bad it's gone you're gonna get a
crash what about something like
dependency injection which is in every
asp net core application and is used in
a very key way by the framework well
I'll tell you something all the
Constructors are only called through
reflection and dynamic code generation
so they're all gone what happens is like
this widget factory service in this
example has no constructor so when the
DI system tries to create it it will
just blow up and say I can't create I
literally cannot create one of these so
all the Constructors are gone what about
your controllers do you reference your
controllers from other parts of your
code does MVC know about your
controllers when you build no they're
gone right so all of these very dynamic
features that are productive that we
love they they sort of interfere with
this right we need some smarts that
configure this kind of thing now the
other problem that you run into here and
there are lots more of these many of
these problems that I just talked about
our occur in spades in asp net and in
libraries that people use in the
community like your dir your validation
or your auto mapper those kind of things
rest sharp great library problem that's
a little bit more common in the BCL and
core FX is something that they call a
choke point API a choke point API is
when you have divergent code paths or
implementations that are behind a
runtime check so in this example I'm
reading an XML config or adjacent config
how do I know which one well I have to
decide at runtime what is the link or
see the linker sees both so you're Jason
can you're Jason serializer is probably
a Meg your XML serializer if it's the
dotnet one is like five so like you
really really only want one of these if
you care about the size maybe you don't
want either so let's look at some oh I
jumped a little too fast let's talk
about what the solutions to those things
might be the solutions to those things
might be it might be that we add smarts
to the linker it might be that we say
okay we're gonna teach the linker about
controllers we're gonna teach the linker
about di we're gonna teach the linker to
recognize all these things that it's a
problem immediately because it doesn't
help you if you're writing a library it
doesn't help
people who maintain Auto mapper or
maintain rest sharp or any of these
other great libraries that people use so
we think that the solution here is
probably something to do with attributes
and annotations and analyzers and a
whole toolchain about making it possible
for people to understand when they're
running when they're writing code that
runs a list of breaking the link or a
breaking link ability it's a lot of work
it's a complicated problem it's not as
simple as saying like well I know that
this library doesn't work with the
linker so oft it out because many times
these libraries are libraries that you
combine with types from other assemblies
so you can't just like block linking on
one assembly that's usually not going to
be enough to solve the problem you
either need to do it at the application
level or you need to build an
understanding with the linker and tools
to try and make it possible to do this
safely so let's look at some perf
results these are the size results and
hopefully this will help show you the a
little bit of the impact in Wow why
we're excited about this so normal
self-contained published 92 megabytes
that's what you get today if you use the
linker and conservative mode which is
something you can do today 74 megabytes
that's something that's within reach for
you you can get there if you turn the
linker up to aggressive mode which is
what I was just talking about and you
have the single file host you can get
down to 42
megabytes based on the current TAC
assuming we make no changes to dotnet so
the work that I did to do to get here is
basically wrote extensibility for the
linker that understand
inna di and understands MVC's
controllers and things like that and
that can get us down to 42 megabytes
we can get down to about the 25 to 28
range by making a bunch of assumptions
about work that we will do in the future
so doing more prototyping coming up with
hard-coded lists of things to delete yes
literally delete from the output and
thinking hard about what those things
are we think that the best case for this
based on the current tech is down around
25 to 28 Meg's depending on what
features you want to be part of that now
the good news here is that which
features you're using inside your app or
which code you write inside your
application and the volume of code you
write inside your application has a very
very small impact on these numbers the
thing that the thing that really changes
this dial is not like how much code did
you write the volume of your code is
probably not going to make a big
difference the thing that does make a
big difference is what are your library
dependencies and what are your library
dependencies within dotnet if you have
one method that calls regex you need all
the regex stuff if you have one method
that calls xml you need all the xml
stuff so making a choice like using XML
for config versus an i and I file or
something like that can have a really
big impact on the size if you get down
to this 28 to 25 megabytes lovell and
just to prove I'm not bluffing this is a
screenshot this is a 25 megabyte
Linux executable single file that works
and runs and is a REST API using JSON
serialization and some of the stuff that
we talked about earlier so basically an
app that's really similar to the one we
looked at in the last demo just to be
very clear about this this is the best
case so this is with us making a lot of
assumptions and hoping for the best and
saying well we think we we think we
might be able to achieve this if we
tried really hard I'm gonna speed up a
little bit I'm almost out of time
so these are some perf results for
startup top line they're what you get
today caveat we always include a single
we always include a request as part of
measuring start up for asp net because
otherwise it would be very easy for us
to cheat by just being lazier and not
doing initialization while main is
running so we always measure main and
first request and then combine them
that's what you're seeing here
so the black line the second one is the
impact of the single-file host it's a
pure just downward shift 30 40
milliseconds of benefit it's no real
trade-off for you the other line the the
sort of melon colored or coral colored
line at 200 is removing MBC and removing
a bunch of Managed features that we're
saying well maybe you don't need it in
this scenario so there's about a hundred
milliseconds of time to get back by
slimming down the amount of code that
needs to run the amount of assemblies
that need to get loaded and so on so the
best thing that you could do to help
this is probably the most experimental
thing we're talking about today love to
hear from people what scenarios do you
have we're using self-contained publish
what would smaller faster dotnet mean
what would you use it for
what are your deployment environments
what are your constraints those kind of
things let's shift gears and we're going
to talk about blazer and electron so
hopefully you're a little bit familiar
with blazer but if you're not you're
gonna get a taste in just a second if
you like what you see and you want to
learn about blazer and go to a good
general blazer talk my friend Steve
Sanderson is gonna be on today a little
bit later in this room I encourage you
to go to his talk and check it out we've
shipped blazer server as part of dotnet
core 3 oh so that's new and we've
officially announced blazer webassembly
support shipping May in 2020 beyond that
what's on the horizon for blazer well we
have lots of ideas about improving tools
we have lots of ideas about supporting
more of what browsers give you and we
have lots of ideas about more language
features and goodies for blazer however
we're also very keen on adding more app
models more hosting models and more ways
to run blazer I'm going to show you a
little bit of a marriage what a marriage
might look like between blazer and
electron and what are some of the things
that that might give you and we've we've
shown some samples of electron and use
before but we haven't really done a deep
dive and we haven't really talked that
much about what the advantages of that
are so let's jump right into that and
just to be a little bit different
because it's blazer and it's special
we're gonna do the demo first this time
so let me get my
Glaser solution here now I like to call
this B electron and everyone else seems
to seems to pronounce it blech Tron and
it kind of hurts me but I guess make up
make up your own mind what you think is
right your interpretation is as valid as
mine so I'll go ahead and get this fired
up this is building ok so I've got my
app and this is just a blazer template
app that I have electron eyes I have put
this inside of an electron shell if
you're not familiar with electron
electron is the desktop application that
powers things like vs code and a bunch
of other stuff it is chromium and node
in a desktop application shell it is
cross-platform it works on every
operating system you'd care about for
desktops and it has a rich ecosystem
with a bunch of features like crash
reporting auto updates installers
publishing and so on and I have taken my
blazer app and I have put it inside this
electron shell and you can see it's
giving me this sort of single page
application kind of feel and activity
and I'm got in the background here the
code for what's on the screen right now
I've got a dotnet event handler hooked
up to an HTML button and when I click
that button you can see my dotnet event
handler code is running is incrementing
that count and blazer is updating that
markup electron all of the UI that
you're seeing here is HTML because it's
chromium so it's the HTML web stack of
technologies in the browser powering the
UI so I had a conversation with my boss
this morning and he said that he's very
concerned about our overuse of this
counter button all of these counter
increments are very precious resources
we pay we pay by the click and his boss
his Ross is a real tightwad I'm here and
so he wants to know is there any way we
could reduce our usage of the counter so
I thought I would gently nag people to
avoid using so much counter and the way
that I want to do that is I want to show
an operating system notification if you
have exceeded your quota for the count
so I'm going to get the notification
service from di this is something that
I've added from the prototype so don't
assume that this exists today
I'll get the notification service and I
want to say if your current count
is greater than or equal to ten then I
want to show you a notification and I
can use this notification service and
you can see I have this this show async
method here and I can give it a
notification options or I can give it a
title and body in the interest of time I
have one that I have written already
here so you don't have to watch me
struggle the type so I'm gonna show you
a rude notification and kind of tell you
off if you exceed your counts I don't
know why that's not building oh because
I need to make this async let's do that
real quick get this going and watch the
bottom-right corner of the screen so I'm
gonna click get to nine the next one
didn't happen okay great well that's
that's ahh because focus assist is on
that's great let's turn off focus assist
now there it is so again my notification
yeah thirteen is really too many I
should probably stop let's do something
else so so notification is interaction
with the operating system easy to do
when you're inside of a desktop
application what else can we do so I
have this fetch data page that's loading
this weather report and sort of pulling
it from the internet and showing it to
you in this nice little UI now I heard
from my boss that he doesn't really like
using this application he doesn't really
like this UI you know I think I've done
a good job on it but he really prefers
Excel and his needs are very important
so it'd be great if we could get this
data somehow into Excel if you've been
to blazer talks before you've probably
seen us do some Excel Interop here so I
can do that I'm gonna copy one of our
previous demos and I'm going to give it
its own little twist so we're gonna
export this data from Excel or from from
the elektron window into Excel and I'm
just going to define this little export
function and I'm gonna totally put it in
the wrong place and stuff up my demo
just a sec so I'm gonna define this
export function I am using a library
here called EP plus I don't feel like
this code is too hard to understand but
basically creating an excel package
adding a worksheet and then it's got
this nice little function where you give
it some
that type and it will just automatically
create columns and rows from that
collection pretty cool pretty convenient
so if I wanted to because it's a blazer
application I could add an HTML button
here and I could say @ on click and I
could have an export button but that's
not very snazzy that doesn't really show
off the power of the electron if I have
to add a button to do that what if I
could add a native context menu to do
that so that is what I'm going to do so
I can get from the cascading parameter
system a parameter that I have defined
if you have not seen cascading
parameters before do not let it throw
you this is just basically a way of
saying this is a value that is passed
down through my UI tree kind of like a
context in react if you're at all
familiar with that if you're not I
apologize but just pretend that I get an
access to the menu somehow and I can do
something and the reason why it's a
cascading parameter and not a DI service
is well I've hooked it up to the routing
system so I can add context menus per
page and then they sort of show when
they're on that page and then they go
away when you're not on that page so I
can scope this functionality to a given
page let's go ahead and define a menu so
for my menu I have this set context menu
method and I will pass a new menu item
and I'm gonna set the label of this to
be export to excel and I'm gonna set my
click action on this menu to call my
export function now the thing that's
missing here is that we haven't really
done anything with this we're just
creating the worksheet we're not putting
it anywhere but because I'm inside
electron and I'm inside of a desktop
application well I could just save it to
the temp directory and I can just open
Excel I can do all those things I don't
have to prompt to you for a file
download which is how this this demo
would normally go I can just do it
directly because I'm on the desktop
machine so let me grab that snippet real
quick and let's give this a try yes that
is
menu also the loading loading so you see
if I come to my counter page I can hit
that context menu and it's empty but if
I come to my fetch data page I can hit
that context menu and I have this nice
native looking context menu here that
says export to excel let's let's hope
there works though so there it is in
Excel inside the blazer process I'm able
to create this worksheet I'm able to
save it to disk and I'm able to open it
and the reason why that works is that
I'm inside of a normal net core process
so all the things that you could do in a
normal net core process with B electron
you can just do skip over that so how
this works
we run your blazer app in Adana core
process which is similar to how blazer
server works we use the electron net
library to control electron so we're
using a third-party library that someone
else has created that's on the internet
there's a link there if you want to
check it out we're using that to boot
electron and manage a lot of the
communication with it inside the
electron renderer process we have a
custom build of Blazers JavaScript
support code and we have a custom
renderer inside of our dotnet process
that's managing the communication
between those two so you have a dotnet
process that's remote controlling
basically a chrome process to give you
an HTML UI the fact that it's a Donette
process means that well you've got that
familiar dotnet programming environment
as well of are all of our existing tools
and diagnostic capabilities that you
have for dotnet so what might this look
like in the future if we chose to invest
in this well we would need to build a
bunch of blazer e ways to do electron
I'm a be showed you a couple in the in
the demo here I had a notice at a
notification service I had a I had a
menu manager kind of thing it would
probably come with us building a bunch
of blazer capabilities for electron
features that we don't have we need to
take a look at the electron API surface
which is extensive and figure out what
of those things you need to be
successful in blazer as well as a bunch
more Docs and recipes in addition the
fact that we'd be doing something like
electron means that we would need a new
tool chain we need Donna build button
Donna build support to build the
electron application Donna published
support to publish it as well as
templates and probably integrations for
you with their crash report
and they're updating service so with
that I'm at time and I'm out of stuff to
say so thanks for coming you can find
these materials online a little bit
later today and I hope you enjoy the
rest of the conference